[♪♪♪]
JESSE: WELCOME TO.
"WATTERS' WORLD."
BACKFIRING ACTIVISM.
HARD CORE DEMOCRATIC ACTIVISTS
ARE THREAT BEING TO OVERWHELM
THE REST OF THE PARTY.
THEY DISRUPT PEACEFUL EVENTS AND
CAUSE VIOLENCE.
THIS WEEK WE SAW A TEENAGER
ATTACKED FOR WEARING A MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN HAT.
IN LOWER MANHATTAN AMERICANS
WERE SIGHTSEEING.
SUDDENLY A RADICAL
AFRICAN-AMERICAN ACTIVIST BEGAN
SCALING THE STATUE OF LIBERTY.
COME DOWN.
POLICE AND FIREMEN WERE
DEPLOYED.
THE ENTIRE LIBERTY ISLAND FILLED
WITH 4,000 TOURISTS WERE
EVACUATED.
3,000 VISITORS WERE TURNED AWAY
ON THE MONUMENT'S BIGGEST DAY OF
TRUMP'S IMMIGRATION POLICY.
SHE WAS BORN IN THE CONGO AND
SHE PROBABLY WON'T EVEN SPEND A
DAY IN JAIL.
AFTER DIVERTING POLICE RESOURCES
FROM FIGHTING REAL CRIME AND
RUINING THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE'S
VISITS TO THE MONUMENT ON JULY
4.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WEIGHED IN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: YOU SEE THAT
CLOWN ON THE STATUE OF LIBERTY?
I WOULD HAVE SAID JUST GET SOME
NETS AND WAIT UNTIL SHE COMES
DOWN.
JESSE: SHE HAS FILED SELF
SEEMINGLY FRIVOLOUS
DISCRIMINATION LAWSUITS.
SHE HAD RUN-INS WITH NEIGHBORS.
SHE HAS BEEN SLAPPED WITH $5,000
IN FINES BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
SANITATION AND SHE HAS BEEN
ARRESTED FORTRESS PASSION AND
ASSAULTING AN OFFICER.
AND SHE SAYS SHE WAS INSPIRED BY
MICHELLE OBAMA.
OUR BELOVED FIRST LADY THAT I
CARE SO MUCH ABOUT.
WHEN THEY GO LOW.
WE GO HIGH.
AND I WENT AS HIGH AS I COULD.
TRUMP HAS WRECKED THIS COUNTRY
APART.
NOTHING YOU CAN SAY TO ME WOULD
JUSTIFY PUTTING CHILDREN IN
CAGES.
ONLY THE STUPID UNINTELLIGENT
COWARDS.
WOULD RIP A TENDER AGE CHILD
FROM HIS MOTHER.
JESSE: I DON'T THINK MICHELLE
OBAMA WANTS AN ENDORSEMENT.
THE PHOTO OF A CHILD IN A CAGE
WAS FROM 2014.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION DID
THAT.
TRUMP DIDN'T PUT THAT KID IN A
CAGE.
FAKE NEWS IS CAUSING REAL RAGE.
WE ALL WANT FAMILIES TO SAY
TOGETHER WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
PROTECTING OUR BORDER AND
YOU WILL REMEMBER BLACK LIVES
MATTERS PROTESTERS DISRUPTED THE
MACY'S THANKSGIVING DAY PARADE
WHILE PARENTS WERE CELEBRATING
THE PARADE WITH THEIR YOUNG
KIDS.
OCCUPY WALL STREET PROTESTERS
SHUT DOWN TRAFFIC IN DETROIT SO
PEOPLE COULDN'T COMMUTE TO WORK
WITH TRUMP'S RHETORIC FIRE
BOMBED A LIMO OWNED BY A MUSLIM
IMMIGRANT.
RAID IN OAKLAND.
>> I.C.E. IS NOT WELCOME IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> WE ARE GOING TO FIGHT BACK.
JESS REQUIRE TURNS OUT I.C.E.
WAS CONDUCTING A RAID ON HUMAN
TKS TRAFFICKERS -- SEX
TRAFFICKERS.
DEMOCRATS WERE PROTESTING
AGAINST THIS.
TRUMP'S APPROVAL RATING IS UP
HARVARD-HARRIS POLL RELEASED A
FEW DAYS AGO.
AMAZING.
NOW THE MOST OF IMPORTANT ISSUE
DETERMINING PEOPLE'S VOTES IN
THE MID-TERMS?
IMMIGRATION.